Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Excusez-moi, je suis un peu en retard,
mais il y avait un con sur la route.
Il roulait à deux à l’heure !
Il accélérait, ralentissait,
mettait son clignotant
un coup à gauche, un coup à droite.
Il ne savait pas conduire !
Il ne savait même pas où il allait.
Quand j’ai réussi à le dépasser,
je l’ai engueulé, je vous le dis.
Je me suis arrêté
puis je l’ai engueulé, le con !
Je venais faire un TEDx
sur l’intelligence,
(Rires)
j’ai décidé de plutôt faire
un TEDx sur les cons.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Oui, les cons.
J’ai même une théorie là-dessus,
ma théorie des cons.
Je vais vous expliquer,
c’est assez simple.
Je suis certain que vous allez
vous en rappeler en sortant d’ici.
D’abord, le con est quand même
une figure omniprésente
dans la culture populaire.
On est abreuvés de l’image
et du concept du con un peu partout,
que ce soit en musique,
au cinéma ou à la télé.
En musique par exemple,
il y a Brassens qui a écrit sur le sujet
et selon lui, quand on est con,
c’est pour la vie.
De façon un peu plus subtile,
on peut penser au Roi des cons,
de Renaud dans « Hexagone »,
(Chante)
Être né sous le signe de l’hexagone
C’est vraiment pas une sinécure
et le roi des cons sur son trône
il est français, ça, j’en suis sûr.
(Fin du chant)
Bon, vous comprendrez qu’on ne cherche pas
vraiment à savoir qui est le roi des cons,
c’est juste un exemple.
Au cinéma, il y a une panoplie de films
qui traitent de la connerie.
On peut penser à « Dumb and Dumber »,
« OSS 117 »
ou plus récemment,
au primé « Adieu les cons ».
Et il y a évidemment
le film iconique sur le sujet,
« Le dîner de cons », qu’on a tous vu.
Vous avez bien vu ce film-là ?
Public : Oui !
Je vais même utiliser
certains de ces personnages
pour illustrer ma théorie.
À la télé, il y a les dessins animés
qu’on montre à nos enfants
dès leur plus jeune âge
et les exemples de cons pleuvent.
Et il y a la publicité.
C'est le rôle de l'homme dans la pub.
Le personnage publicitaire
de l’homme idiot est un grand classique.
Les trois-quarts du temps,
les gars sont stupides,
incapables de résoudre
des problèmes simples.
Ils ont besoin qu’on vienne
avec le produit miracle
pour régler leurs soucis en deux secondes.
Complètement cons, les mecs.
Donc le con est omniprésent
dans la culture populaire,
ce qui nous amène peu à peu,
inconsciemment, à croire
en l’existence des cons.
Il y a vraiment des cons parmi nous.
Ici même !
(Rires)
D’autres avant moi
ont élaboré des théories des cons.
On peut penser au théorème
du con de Yann Pérodin.
Sans rentrer dans les détails
de l’équation,
vous comprendrez que ça demeure
quand même humoristique.
Mais à la différence des autres théories,
ma théorie des cons ne cherche pas
à prouver l’existence des cons,
mais bien à expliquer les conséquences
de croire en l’existence des cons.
Vous voyez la nuance ?
C'est important, vous verrez.
Donc si j’en reviens à ma théorie,
c’est assez basique.
Car on garde les choses simples pour être
sûr que tout le monde puisse comprendre.
(Rires)
D’abord, il y a deux types de cons.
Il y a le con idiot personnifié ici
par Jacques Villeret.
C’est quelqu’un qui a
une intelligence inférieure à la moyenne.
QI autour de 80.
Il ne comprend pas les enjeux complexes,
les blagues, le second degré.
Pas rapide, rapide, disons.
En connaissez-vous ?
Bon, ce type de con-là, on va l’appeler
le con idiot pour faire simple.
Le deuxième type de con, c’est
plutôt le mec qui parle mal aux gens,
qui les traite de façon irrespectueuse
ou qui grosso modo
se place en position de supériorité
et se permet de dénigrer
les autres de façon générale.
On va lui donner le titre
de con trou du cul
(Rires)
ou juste trouduc pour faire court.
C’est l’emmerdeur royal tel que
représenté par T. Lhermitte
dans Le Dîner de cons.
Ma théorie est simple,
j’ai même décidé de vous l’illustrer.
Quand une personne croit
en l’existence des cons idiots,
elle se permet
de traiter les autres individus
qu’elle croit plus idiots que la moyenne
irrespectueusement,
de façon dégradante, de façon impolie,
devenant par le fait même un con trouduc.
Voyez-vous, c’est quelque chose
qui s’auto-réalise.
On croit aux cons, alors on devient
nous-mêmes con en agissant comme un con.
C’est ce qu’on peut appeler
une prophétie auto-réalisatrice
ou un genre de spirale
descendante de la connerie.
(Rires)
Vous comprendrez qu’on assiste aussi
au phénomène de la transmutation du con,
en passant d’une catégorie
de con à l’autre.
Je ne vais pas rentrer dans les détails
de la théorie avancée des cons.
Faudrait pas qu’on perdre
qui que ce soit en chemin, hein.
(Rires)(Applaudissements)
Plus on croit qu’il y a des cons,
plus on agit en con,
et effectivement, plus il y a de cons.
Voyez-vous, c’est l’essentiel
de ma théorie.
Il y a plein de façons de la démontrer.
On peut penser à mon exemple du début :
je suis en voiture,
il y a quelqu’un devant moi qui roule
trop lentement, ça en est agaçant.
Je ne cherche pas à comprendre.
Est-ce moi-même qui roulais trop vite ?
Est-ce que je suivais de trop près ?
Est-ce qu’il cherchait une adresse ?
Était-il en train de changer de radio ?
De parler à ses enfants
qui pleuraient derrière ?
Je ne cherche pas à savoir :
c’est un gros con, je l’ai engueulé,
Théorie prouvée.
(Rires)
On peut penser au milieu du travail.
On peut trouver que
quelqu’un est un peu inefficace.
Le collègue qui ne répond
jamais vite aux courriels
et qui prend toujours trop de pauses.
Vous voyez le genre ?
On va vite traiter différemment la
personne en l’invitant moins aux réunions,
en voulant moins collaborer avec elle,
ou même en lui parlant comme
si c’était un animal de compagnie
ou un bébé un peu débile.
(Rires)
Il y a peut-être plein de raisons
qui peuvent expliquer cela.
Peut-être qu’elle est surmenée, qu’elle
cumule deux postes depuis deux ans
ou qu’elle pense constamment à sa femme ou
son mari couchant avec quelqu’un d’autre.
Mais on ne cherche pas à comprendre,
on donne vite l’étiquette de con idiot,
en devenant nous-même con
en la traitant de façon irrespectueuse.
C’est important de le mentionner,
ma théorie des cons est unisexe.
Ça peut autant être un con qu’une conne.
C’est inclusif.
(Rires)
Le postulat de base de ma théorie -
en passant, vous pouvez me citer :
Pierre-Yves Charpentier, 2022.
Je prépare quelques articles sur le sujet
qui seront publiés prochainement.
Mon postulat de base,
c’est que fondamentalement,
il n’y a personne de foncièrement con.
Le con idiot n'existe pas.
Blague à part, je ne crois pas
en l’existence des cons.
Je pense que c'est une catégorisation
rapide, une sorte de mécanisme de défense
qu’on s’est créé pour se trouver
soi-même raisonnable tout le temps.
Pensez-y.
Et si on ne croyait pas au con idiot ?
Peut-être qu’il y aurait moins
de cons trous du cul.
(Rires)
Peut-être qu’on se poserait la question
avant d’être tout de suite irrespectueux
envers quelqu’un d’autre.
Je pense que de se dire que
le con idiot n’existe pas
est un pari toujours gagnant.
Ça rendrait tout le monde
moins con, en fait.
Rappelez-vous la télé, la radio,
la publicité, le cinéma,
nous bercent depuis l’enfance dans la
croyance que les cons existent réellement
et sont parmi nous.
On est tous biaisés et encouragés
à croire à l’existence des cons.
On a tous été élevés
dans la culture du con, en fait.
Alors, je vais vous inviter à un petit
exercice de visualisation, d’accord ?
Fermez les yeux.
Tout le monde a les yeux fermés ? Ok.
Ne vous inquiétez pas,
ça ne durera pas longtemps.
Tout le monde a bien les yeux fermés ?
Je ne veux pas voir un con
avec les yeux ouverts, hein !
(Rit)
Les yeux fermés,
les yeux fermés, s’il vous plaît.
Imaginez-vous un monde
où les cons idiots n’existent pas.
Un monde où il n'y a pas
d'idiots dans les pubs.
Où on ne peut pas traiter quelqu’un
en voiture spontanément de con
parce que le concept de con n’existe pas.
C’est assez révolutionnaire ce que je vous
demande, mais essayez d’imaginer, ok ?
Alors là,
peut-être,
peut-être qu’on se rendrait compte
que les gens agissent
parce qu’ils ont des raisons,
des raisons qu’on peut comprendre.
Ça serait pas mal.
Allez, vous pouvez rouvrir les yeux.
(Applaudissements)
Pour terminer, je sais que ma conférence
ne changera pas votre vie,
même si je suis un expert
international de la connerie.
Je sais qu'en sortant de mon TEDx, vous
allez quand même traiter quelqu'un de con.
C’est beaucoup trop ancré,
tant chez vous que chez moi.
Mais la prochaine fois que
vous traitez quelqu’un de con,
posez-vous la question :
« En ce moment, qui est
le plus con de nous deux au juste ?
Lui ou moi ? »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)